- Thank you! Bye!
- Situé au coeur
du quartier chinois,
Tap Phong existe depuis 1989.
La boutique a été fondée par
le grand-père de Lili Tran.
"Il voulait offrir
une vie meilleure à sa famille
et s'assurer que ses descendants
puissent poursuivre son rêve",
dit-elle.
Mais le développement
immobilier et l'embourgeoisement
menacent la communauté.
De nombreux commerçants
et restaurateurs tentent
toujours de se relever,
après un an et demi de pandémie.
Depuis quelques mois,
les représentants des
communautés chinoises de
Montréal, Winnipeg, Edmonton,
Calgary, Vancouver et Toronto
demandent au gouvernement
fédéral un plan pour
protéger leurs quartiers
d'un océan à l'autre.
Elle rêve d'un statut
patrimonial et d'un plan
d'action pour assurer
le développement économique
du quartier chinois à Toronto.
Mais la loi municipale est
limitée : elle ne protège
que les bâtiments.
MEGAN IP, cofondatrice
de l'agence de comm. Spectre
- C'est pas une question
de simplement préserver
les bâtiments, mais aussi
préserver la culture,
les mémoires, les souvenirs
des gens qu'ils ont du quartier
chinois. Je pense que c'est ça
qui est le plus menançant.
La deuxième chose, c'est
vraiment un centre communautaire
culturel au coeur du quartier
chinois pour avoir au moins
cette place-là pour dire :
OK, ça, c'est protégé.
- Et les éléments culturels
d'un espace n'ont aucune
protection, se désole
le conseiller municipal
du quartier.
Il suggère d'interdire
aux propriétaires de louer
des espaces à de grandes chaînes
afin que les petites entreprises
puissent prospérer.
À Montréal, la mairesse
y est allée de son propre
plan d'action pour protéger
et relancer son quartier chinois
il y a deux semaines.
La Ville compte notamment
développer des logements
sociaux, offrir un meilleur
accès piétonnier au quartier
et accompagner la communauté
dans la création d'une
association de commerçants.
Un modèle qui, selon certains,
pourrait inspirer d'autres
municipalités canadiennes
à protéger ce patrimoine.
Ici Camille Fereisen,
Radio-Canada, Toronto.